- Paris is getting married,
so congratulations.
- [Kelly] That's so exciting!
- [Hilton] Thank you.
- [Kelly] So, are you helping with that?
- (crowd claps)
- I am really- I'm just looking at myself.
Gosh, I need my roots done.
- [Kelly] You look amazing.
Oh my God. You should see
yourself, how I see you.
You walked in and I was
like fabulous, okay.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- My hair gets really
frizzy in this weather.
- [Kelly] Oh, mine does too, who cares?
- Right. Who cares?
- [Kelly] Yeah, you look
great. Yeah. Do you-
But you're great at
like planning and stuff,
So I figured you'd probably
help with her wedding stuff, right?
- [Hilton] I am helping,
but I've hired Mindy Weiss
to hold my hand.
- Ah.
- Because I am A.D.D.
- (crowd laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh, I'm A.D.H.D.
- E F G, and so is Paris.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I know I can get- I
could do it all on my own.
- Yeah.
- But then I would lose the guest list,
and it's got to be seated at some point.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You do have to seat people.
- [Kelly] Yes, people
get weird about seating.
- You know what though?
I believe that people like a home.
They like to know they have a place to go.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Because if they don't, like
I know that my husband and I,
when we go to a party, I'll
stop talking with this group,
this group, this group.
And then I'm standing there
with my plate of food.
And then I walk up and all of a sudden,
there's one chair left
at this table, one there.
And he's like, Kathy, you're sitting there
talking with everybody and
we're at different tables.
So, sorry.
- Oh. But that's kind of exciting.
You talk to each other
all the time, you know?
- (crowd laughs)
- And you don't Want your husband,
or your boyfriend or your girl, whatever,
sitting next to somebody
that you don't like.
- (crowd laughs)
- Or it's kind of nice though,
because then you get, well, there's that,
- (crowd laughs)
but then there, but then there's also,
you get to like talk to people,
you probably heard each
other stories, a ton.
So you're like, I'm more
interested in this one.
- You know what? I just
want to be with my friends.
- I'd probably just take the
plate and hang with myself.
- (crowd laughs)
- I just want to eat my food, really.
That's all I want to do.
- I love it. But so-
- I went to a corner.
- She didn't actually,
When Paris was here,
she is actually super cool,
like, congratulations.
Like, What a kind individual.
- She said say hi, and she sends her love.
- (crowd clapping)
- [Kelly] Like she's such a kind person.
And I thought she doesn't come
across as like a bridezilla.
She, she kind of-
- She is easy breezy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's him. I love him-
- [Kelly] Oh, I love it.
- But I'm gonna tell you people,
- [Kelly] It's the guy.
- This guy is, I call him an octopus.
He's got those mitts in everything.
- Oh, he likes to, Yeah.
- [Hilton] He, I call
Him Octopus Groomzilla.
he's an O.G.
- Oh my Gosh. You know what?
They're imperfect though.
She's kind of breezy about
it. So one of them had to be.
- She, I yelled at her
the other day and I said,
Paris, you know what?
This is ridiculous. I am
the mother of the bride.
I am planning this wedding with you.
I said, if you were to
walk down the street
and ask 100 people-
He went ahead and started
calling about the band.
- (crowd laughs)
About a hotel, about all
the different arrangements.
I said, I am the mother of the bride.
I would be mad if my mom said that to me.
She goes, "No, he just means well."
I would be like,
"Mom, don't insult me and talk
about my fiance like that."
- [Kelly] I love that.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Well she recognizes,
you're both dominant maybe?
- (laughs)
Maybe she's like, I'm going to lay low.